ก็
สวัสดีครับ
พี่ค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้เรียนโอเคอ่ะสวัสดีครับ
สวัสดีค่ะวันนี้ครับ
วันนี้ที่เราคุยกันเป็นวันอะไรคะอันนี้
ใช่ไหมครับวันนี้วันที่ 5 วันนี้ขวดเท่า
ไหร่จะวันนี้วันพุธก่อนวันนี้วันพุธครับ
หาวันนี้วันพุธให้แล้วไหนอ่านี่วันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะอ้าวันพุธที่ 13 ครับวัน
นี้
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนนี้เดือนเมษายนครับ
นี้อา
มีธอสอะไรคะปีพตต
2565 ครับ
แล้วปีกพ.ศ.อะไรคะอ้าปีคศ 2000  4  22
ครับนี่
หน้า 2022
k5 วันนี้วันที่ 4  3
โอเควันนี้วันที่ 13 เดือนเมษายนเนี่ย
น้องเรียนรู้ไหมเป็นวันอะไรของประเทศไทย
เป็นตามส่งดีถ้าช้าๆ 13  14  15 เป็นวัน
สงกรานต์นะครับน้าแต่พี่นิดเราก็ไม่ได้
เล่นสงกรานต์อาจจะมีเล่นนิดหน่อยเป็นนิด
หน่อยนะครับหมาเล่นกับเปียตี้เองหรือ
เปล่าฮ่าๆๆเล่นกับลูกๆที่บ้านอ่าแต่กับ
หรือว่าแบบสาดน้ำตัวเองแล้วตัวเองอาบน้ำ
เพลงเรียกว่าอาบน้ำครับอาบน้ำ
ไปแก้อ้าววันนี้วันสงกรานต์นะครับขอให้
ทุกคนให้นักเรียนทุกคน
มีความสุขนะคนไทยคนไทยพูดว่าสุขสันต์วัน
สงกรานต์เย้สุขสันต์วันสงกรานต์ครับน้อง
เรียมมาสงกรานต์ค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้โอเคอ้าววัน
นี้วันนี้เข้ามาคุยกันกี่โมงครับวันนี้
ตอนนี้
11:15 น
11:00 น 5 นาทีโอเคเป็นตอนเช้าเนาะโอเค
ครับ 5 วันนี้พี่อาร์ตี้มีหนังเรื่อง
หนึ่งสมันเล่าให้น้องเรียนฟังอ่ะน้อง
เรียมเคยดูหนังเรื่อง what  Woman  want
ไหมครับเรื่องนี้เรื่องนี้ไม่เคยค่ะอ้าว
ไม่เคยดูหรอเรื่องนี้หนังดังมากมีคนหลายๆ
คนเคยดูมาแล้วอ่ะตีคิดว่ามีนักเรียน
คะนักเรียนที่กำลังดูเราอยู่ก็เคยดู
เรื่องนี้หน้าแต่น้องเรียนไม่เคยดู
ไม่เคยดูเรียมดูหนังน้อยมากอ๋ออ๋อตูน
5 ดูการ์ตูนเยอะกว่าใช่ไหมดูการ์ตูนเยอะ
ดูหนังน้อยโอเคเดี๋ยวเฮียตี๋จะเล่าให้ฟัง
ว่าวัดบัวแม่น want ในเรื่องเนี้ยเป็น
เรื่องเกี่ยวกับอะไรน้า
เรื่องนี้ก็เป็นเรื่องเกี่ยวกับผู้หญิง
ครับเพราะว่าเป็นเรื่องที่ผู้ชายคนนี้อ่า
เขาชื่อนะเขาชื่ออะไรครับชื่อนิกนิกแมะ
แล้วก็คนนี้ชื่ออ่ะดาซี่
ห่าเค้าตาสวยมากเลยค่ะพี่อ่าใช่ครับนิด
เข้าตาสีฟ้าใช่แล้วสวยนะครับส่วนดาซี่
สหัสสีเขียว
ก็
ไม่เหมือนเราสองคนนะก็ 2 คนนิตาสีดำหน้า
ใช่ครับคนไทยคนไทยส่วนใหญ่ส่วนใหญ่ตาสีดำ
ใจ
อ้าโอเคในเรื่องนี้อ่านมิกจับดาซี่นะครับ
นิเขาทำงานอยู่ที่บริษัทแห่งนึงนะครับอ่า
ก็ทำงานอยู่กับอันนี้คนนี้วันนี้เป็นนี้
คนนี้เป็นหัวหน้าของนี้เป็นหัวหน้าของนี้
นะนิดทำงานให้กับหัวหน้า
แล้วก็มีวันนึงวันนึงหัวหน้าของนิดน่ะก็
ไปให้ดาร์ซี่เนี่ยเข้ามาทำงานเข้ามาทำงาน
ที่นี่ถ้ามาทำงานกับมิคูกัน
หน้ามาช่วยกันทำงานแต่นี้ก็นี้ก็กำลังคิด
ว่าอาจะจะสระจะทำงานกับดาร์ซี่ได้หรือ
เปล่าคนนี้เนี่ยไม่ค่อยไม่ก็ไม่รู้เรื่อง
เกี่ยวกับผู้หญิง
อ้าใช่ครับ
เนื้อมันเกี่ยวกับงานที่เขาทำเหรอครับใช่
ครับเพราะว่าในงานผู้หญิงอ่าในงานที่เขา
ทำเนี่ยเขาต้องอ่า
คิดคิดเกี่ยวกับสินค้าเกี่ยวกับของที่จะ
เอาไปขายให้กับผู้หญิง
5 เอาของไปขายให้กับผู้หญิงหัวหน้าก็เลย
หาผู้หญิงมาช่วยช่วยให้นิดช่วยกันทำงานจะ
ได้ขายของได้เยอะๆนะอ่าซ้ายครับพอนิค
เนี่ยไม่เก่งนิดไม่เก่งเรื่องผู้หญิงอ่า
ไม่รู้ว่าผู้หญิงชอบอะไรไม่รู้ว่าผู้หญิง
คลิปอะไรหน้าไม่รู้ไม่รู้ว่าผู้หญิงคิด
อะไรนิดไม่รู้ไม่รู้
ทำยังไงคะพี่อตินฮะโอเคได้โอเคอ่ะอ่าตอน
ที่ทำงานดาซี่ดาซี่ก็เลยเอาของเอาของต่าง
ๆของผู้หญิงเอาไปให้มิกซ์ทดลองทดลองใช้จะ
ได้รู้ว่าผู้หญิงรู้สึกยังไง
น้าเอาของผู้หญิงอย่างเช่นลิปสติก
ไปให้มิกซ์ลองใช้ครีมต่างๆเอาให้นิคลอง
ใช้นิเจอร์รู้ว่าออกทำไมผู้หญิงถึงชอบ
ทำไมผู้หญิงถึงชอบทาลิปทำไมถึงชอบสวยงาม
ผู้หญิงรู้สึกยังไง
ตายครับนี่ครับมีมีของหลายอย่างที่นิคเอา
ไปลองใช้หนี้เขามันไม่ใช่ตอนนี้กำลังทำ
อะไรรู้ไหมครับ
นิกกำลังอะไรค่ะอ่ากำลังโปรดคนหลังอ่ะใช่
ครับและฝนไว้ให้ขนอ่ะจ๊ะนะครับนะแว็กซ์ขน
แบบนี้แต่นะคนที่คิดว่านักเรียนหลายๆคนก็
รู้จักอาการแวกซ์ขนนี่ครับนักเรียนเคยแวะ
คนนะครับแวกซ์ขนคือมีมั้ยเคย
เคยเคยอ่าเก็บชายครับใช้แผ่น
ใช้แผ่นอันนี้แปะลงไปแตะลงไปบนขาแล้วก็
ดึงออก
หาใช้ครับลงไปแล้วก็ดึงออก Hot ดึงออกมา
ขนก็จะไม่มี
หน้าตอนที่ยังไม่ดึงก็จะมีขนใช่ไหมอ่ะอ้า
มีขนแล้วก็ 8 แล้วดึงอันนี้ออกขนก็จะไม่
มีก็จะไม่มีขน
หน้าทรายครับนี้เขาก็เขาก็เลยลองละของ
แว็กซ์คน
อ่ะพ่อไปค่ะฮะนิคไม่ชอบครับเพราะว่าผู้
ชายผู้ชายจะมีขน
ดีมากคนเยอะมากได้ครับ 5 แล้วตอนที่ดึง
ตอนที่ดึงนี้ก็เจ็บมากเจ็บมากจึงขนเอามา
ฮ่าๆ
ทรายครับอ่าโอเคตอนที่เขาดึงออกมานี่ก็
เจ็บมากมีก็เอ่อล้มลงไปล้มลงไปในอ่างอาบ
น้ำในตอนนี้ตอนนี้นิดอยู่ในห้องน้ำนะป่าน
นี้ก็ล้มลงไปในอ่างอาบน้ำนะครับในอ่างอาบ
น้ำเนี่ยมีน้ำอยู่มีน้ำอยู่ในอ่างขางตอน
ที่นิคล้มลงไปในอ่างอาบน้ำ
มีไดร์เป่าผม
ไดร์เป่าผมที่วางอยู่ข้างๆครับนี่ครับ
ไดร์เป่าผมไดร์เป่าผมที่เป่าผม
ไดร์เป่าผมจะเกิด
อะไรขึ้น 5 จะมีมันต้องได้เป่าผมก็ต้อง
ใช้ไฟด้วยใช้ไฟฟ้าเพราะฉะนั้นไดร์เป่าผม
ตกลงไปในอ่างน้ำที่มีตกลงไปนี้ก็เลยโดนไฟ
ดูด
อ่าใช่ครับแต่นี้ไม่เป็นอะไรไม่ตายยังหาย
ไม่ตายเดี๋ยวค่อยดูดนิดเดียวแล้วไฟก็ดับ
หน้าใช่ครับถ้าเกิดนิดตายเรื่องนี้ก็จะจบ
หากใช่ครับจะอบเลยนิคยังไม่ตายอะนิดโดนไฟ
ดูดนิดเดียวนิดเดียวหน้าตานี้ก็หลับไป
หลับไปนิดลองมิกซ์แวกซ์ขนตอนประมาณอ่า
ครวญตี้คิดว่านิกแน็กขนประมาณ 19:00 น
19:00 นแล้วนิกส์โดนไฟดูดโดนไฟดูดแล้ว
Nikon หลับไปนิดตื่นมาแล้วไปก็จริงกี่
โมงตอนเช้า
ว่า 08:00 นแต่ตื่นขึ้นมา
ห่าแล้วนี้ก็ไปทำงาน
หน้า
เด็กไม่ไปโรงพยาบาลก่อนละเห็นอะไรแล้วเขา
ออกฤทธิ์ใช่เขาต้องไปทำงานปกติแต่ตอนนี้
ตอนที่นี้เข้าไปทำงานนิกเริ่มมีอ่าความ
รู้สึกว่านิครู้นิได้ยิน
ได้ยินอะไรคิดได้ยินความคิดความคิดของคน
อื่น
หาอ่าใช่ครับได้ยินดาซี่ไม่ได้พูดจาสิ้น
ไม่ได้พูดได้ที่อยู่เฉยดาซี่คลิปดาซี่คิด
อยู่
ที่ดาวแต่นิคนิครู้นิรู้ความคิดของผู้
หญิง
หวานๆๆ
ตัว 8 ดาวดาวซี่ไม่รู้ไม่รู้วันนี้กับรู้
รู้ว่านี้แกะได้ยินได้ยินดาซี่คิดนะแต่
นิครู้คนเดียวที่คิดอะไรเรียกดาซี่ก็คิด
เรื่องงาน
คิดเกี่ยวกับงานว่าจะทำงานยังไงดีทำงาน
ยังไงให้เกิดสินค้าขายได้เยอะๆนะครับอ่ะ
คิดสินค้าหลายๆแบบแล้วนี้นิกก็ช่วยคิดเอา
ความคิดของดาร์ซี่มาคลิปต่อแล้วก็พูด
แล้วนิคได้ยินเสียงความคิดของผู้ชายในอ่ะ
ไม่ได้ยินนิดไม่ได้ยินผิดผู้ชายนิดได้ยิน
เสียงของผู้หญิงเท่านั้น
ผู้หญิงแตะผู้หญิงผู้หญิงผู้หญิงหลายๆคน
ใช้หลายคนใช่ครับหน้าได้ยินเสียงของผู้
หญิงหลายๆคนต่อตอนแรกที่นี่อยากได้ยิน
เสียงของดาร์ซี่คนเดียวนี่ก็ไม่เชื่อนี้
ก็ไปทดลองไปหาผู้หญิงคนอื่นเดินไปใกล้ๆ
ผู้หญิงคนอื่นนะครับอ้าว่าผู้หญิงคนอื่น
เวลาคิดเนี่ยได้ยินไหมอ่านี่ก็ไปทดสอบไป
ลองเรียนลองเรียนโยคะแล้วค่ะที่มีผู้หญิง
เยอะๆนะครับนี้ก็ได้ยินได้ยินผู้หญิงทุกๆ
คนคิดได้ยินหมดเลยอย่าคิดอะไรบ้างคะผู้
หญิงคิดหลายอย่างเลยบางคนก็คิดว่าอานิ
เข้ามาทำอะไรที่นี่ทำไมถึงหาที่มีเพราะ
ที่นี่มีแต่ผู้หญิงใช่ไหมครับ 5 แต่นิก
เป็นผู้ชายทำไมนิคมาอยู่ที่นี่อ่าใช่ครับ
หลายๆคนก็คิดคิดแต่นี่ก็นี้ก็ได้ยินแต่
นี้ก็ไม่พูดอะไร
วันนี้ต้องการต้องการจะฟังฟัง
คือเรื่องของผู้หญิงว่าผู้หญิงคิดอะไรพูด
อะไรรู้สึกอะไรนิอยากจะรู้
น้าใช้ครับ
แล้วตอนนี้ตอนนี้นิก็รู้เรื่องผู้หญิง
เยอะแล้วหน้านี้ก็เลยสามารถทำงานคู่กับ
ดาร์ซี่ได้นะครับน้า
แล้วก็ทำให้ทำให้อ่าหัวหน้าอ้าหัวหน้าของ
ของนิคชอบชอบงานที่ทั้งสองคนทำด้วยกันนะ
ครับน้า
ที่นี่ที่นี่พอหัวหน้าเห็นว่าอ้าวนิกก็ทำ
ได้นิก็เข้าใจผู้หญิงแล้วนะครับนะก็เลย
คิดว่าเอ่ออ่าจากไม่จ้างด่า 4 แล้ว
หาใช่ครับก็จะหรือว่ายังไงคะเพราะว่านิค
นิคก็คิดได้นี่ก็ทำได้แต่แต่หัวหน้าไม่
รู้ไม่รู้ว่าที่นิคคิดได้เป็นเพราะนิครู้
ความคิดของดาร์ซี่
หาใช่ไหมครับแต่ทีนี้ถ้าดาซี่ไม่อยู่นี่
ก็จะคิดเหมือนผู้หญิงไม่ได้แล้วนะครับห่า
ได้ครับแล้วที่นี้เขาทำยังไงคะอ่ะแต่ตอน
นี้คนที่บอกหัวหน้าไหมอ่านิคบอกหัวหน้า
ครับแต่ตอนนี้เนี่ย
อนิคเริ่มชอบชอบดาซี่แล้ว
นิคชอบกับดาร์ซี่แล้วนะเริ่มรักกันแล้ว
ครับตอนนี้ที่นี้พอหัวหน้าหัวหน้าบอกบอก
กับนิคว่าเอ่อจะไม่จ้างไม่จ้างด่าซี่และ
ไม่ให้ดาร์ซี่ทำงานที่นี่แล้วเพราะว่านิค
ทำได้นี้ก็เลยบอกบ่มีความจริงว่าไม่ใช่
ความคิดของเขาเขาไม่ได้เป็นคนคิดหน้าทั้ง
หมดเป็นความคิดของดาร์ซี่แล้วเขาก็ช่วย
นิดหน่อยช่วยนิดหน่อยของดาร์ซี่คิดเยอะ
กว่า
ได้ครับน้องหัวหน้าว่ายังไงบ้างคะหัวหน้า
ก็บอกว่าแต่หัวหน้าจ้างได้แค่คนเดียวให้
ทำงานได้แค่คนเดียวน้าถ้าดาซี่ทำงานนี้ก็
จะไม่ได้ทำงานถ้านิกทำงานดาซี่ก็จะไม่ได้
ทำงาน
อ้าวใช่ครับนี้ก็เลยกลับไปกลับไปหาดาซี่
แม่ครับแต่ระหว่างทางระหว่างทางที่นิค
กลับกลับบ้านไปหาดาซี่นะครับไอ้บอกกับ
ดาร์ซี่ว่า
อ่าหัวหน้าจะไม่จ้างดาซี่นะครับอ่ะแต่
ระหว่างทางท่าทางที่นิคอ่ากลับไปก็เลย
เหรออนิดเดินไปแล้วก็มีฝนตกมีฝนตกนะครับ
แล้วก็มีฟ้าผ่าลงมา
แต่ขาไม่ได้โดนนิคหน้าผากใกล้ๆกับนิคนิค
เดินมาใกล้ๆแล้วฟ้าผ่า
เปรี้ยงๆเอาฟ้าผ่าเปรี้ยงลงมางานนิดจะโดน
ไฟ The ช่านี้ก็ตกใจแต่ไม่โดนไฟช็อตไม่
เป็นอะไรนี่ก็ไม่คิดอะไรก็เดินไปนะครับ
หน้าแต่ฟ้าผ่าเนี้ยทำให้มิกซ์ทำให้นิคไม่
ไม่ไม่ได้ยินเสียงผู้หญิงอีกแล้วอ้านิ
กลับมาเป็นคนปกติเหมือนเดิม
[เพลง]
ใช่ครับหน้าแล้วนี้ก็เลยไปบอกดาซี่หน้าไป
บอกดาซี่ว่านี้กะลาออก
ขอลาออกไม่ทำงานแล้วนิคไม่ทำงานแล้วแล้ว
ก็ให้ดาร์ซี่อ่ะไปทำงานเหมือนเดิม
แล้วเด๊ RC ว่ายังไงคะอ่ะนี่โอเคมั้ย
ดาซี่ก็โอเคนะครับเพราะว่าอัดไอดาร์ซี่ก็
รู้แล้วว่าถ้าดาซี่ได้ทำงานนิก็จะต้องไม่
ได้ทำงานน้าใช่ครับแต่ทั้งคู่ทั้งคู่ก็
ตอนนี้ทั้งคู่ก็รักกันแล้วแล้วก็ก็อยู่
ด้วยกันอยู่ด้วยกันอ้ะก็ก็ให้ดาร์ซี่ไปทำ
งานแล้วก็นี้ก็อยู่ที่บ้านแล้วก็ไปหาหา
งานใหม่ทำ
นาอายครับ
อ้าเรื่องของครับจบหรือยังเนี้ยจบแล้ว
ครับเรื่องแล้วซีวอนก็เลยจบแค่นี้ใจครับ
ของเรื่องนี้น้าน้องแอมอ่าคิดยังไงเกี่ยว
กับถ้ามีถ้ามีผู้ชายรู้ดูทุกความคิดของ
ผู้หญิงได้หาไข้ถ้าเพียงตีทัพพญาตีรู้
ความคิดของน้องเรียมได้น้องเรียนคิดว่าจะ
เป็นยังไงครับ
อ่าถ้าถ้าพี่อาร์ตี้ไม่บอกเรียนนะเล่มก็
จะเอาก็ดีเพื่อตีรู้ว่าแบบเรียมจะพูดอะไร
อยากทำอะไรแล้วเรียบก็ไม่ไม่ต้องพูดแต่
ว่าถ้าเกิดเรียนรู้ว่าพี่รู้ความคิดเรียม
เรียมกูจะรู้สึกกลัวฮ่าๆออกกลัวด้วยครับ
เพราะว่าเพราะว่าเราเราจะคิดคิดตลอดเวลา
พี่อาร์ตี้ก็คิดตลอดเวลาใช่ครับนะถ้ามีคน
มารู้ว่าเราคิดอะไรแบบนี้ก็จะมีดี
ใช่ไหมครับเราก็คิดคิดดีบางทีเราก็คิดไม่
ดีฮ่าๆอะไรครับรู้ใช่บางอย่างบ้าสิ่งที่
เราคิดเราก็ไม่ได้อยากให้คนอื่นรู้สิ่ง
ที่เราคิดใช่ไหมครับ
กูสนุกมากค่ะนั้นเรื่องนี้ใช่ครับต้องไป
ดูครับนี่เรื่อง what  Woman  want หนัง
เรื่องนี้เครียดที่คิดว่าน่าจะอ่าประมาณ
ประมาณ 20 ปีแล้วนะยี่สิบปี
เก่ามากดูเท่าไหร่กี่ปีที่แล้วดูตั้งแต่
กี่ปีที่แล้วเนี่ยเดี๋ยวตีก็ดูมา
จำไม่ได้แล้วดูตั้งแต่ตอนที่มันออกหนัง
ขายใหม่ๆ HD ก็เป็นดูให้ดูประมาณ 20 ปี
ที่แล้ว
ไอเอา
ดีมาก
โอเคอ้าวันนี้สนุกไหมครับนักเรียน
อ่านนักเรียนอะมีนักเรียนคนไหนที่เคยดู
เรื่องนี้แล้วอ้าแล้วชอบเรื่องนี้ comment
comment บอกเพียงตีข้างล่างได้นะครับก็
เห็นบอกน้องเรียมได้นะครับผมว่าชอบเรียก
ก็อยากรู้
ใช่แล้วก็อยากรู้เหมือนกันว่านักเรียน
อยากฟังความคิดของผู้หญิงไหม aye  aye
อาหาร
โอเคอ่าดีครับแล้วก็ถ้างั้นเดี๋ยวคราว
หน้าล็อคกลับมาเจอกันอีกนะครับแต่ค่อยมา
ติดตามกันในช่องคอม Person โบว์ไทยนะครับ
ว่าเฮียตีกับมาเรียนนะครับจะมันเล่า
เรื่องอะไรให้ฟังกันนะครับโอเคสำหรับวัน
นี้ต้องลาไปก่อนแล้วค่ะค่ะเดี๋ยวลาไปเล่น
น้ำสงกรานต์ก่อนมั้ย
สวัสดีครับสวัสดีครับนักเรียนดีถ้าเพียง
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนไปเล่นสงกรานต์สงกรานต์
สงกรานต์
สาดเข้าของได้ไหมไม่ได้อ่ะ
ม.ค